i looked for opportunities to build
things and make things different at the
beginning i was fascinated by biology
then by the i.t industry and helping
customers doing things
and these days i had the opportunity to
combine both and to
combine agriculture and biology with
technology and they really find it
fascinating their combination
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
talking about saffron
meet tal wilk glazer the ceo of saffron
tech
pal has over 20 years of experience in
leading international technology and
communications companies she served as
salesforce industries regional director
of eastern europe africa and israel and
accompanied large companies in the
process of digital transformation
prior to salesforce she served in
executive positions in velocity and is
one of the founders of vebo
tal holds a bachelor's degree in medical
sciences from the hebrew university of
jerusalem and a master's degree in
business administration from the
technolon institute of technology
i'm really excited to
talk to you about you know your career
and your journey and the the different
transitions you've made which are not
not that trivial uh today you're in
saffron tech previously with salesforce
and with a variety of other companies
and so a lot to uncover over these 20
minutes and and i have to start by by
asking you know you you know tal what
what are you know how how do you
how do you look back on your journey and
identify the key points that you've had
there
so
i think that when i'm looking at my
journey i love building things it's not
really matter what i'm building whether
it's a treehouse or building a software
at the end of the day what i'm
fascinating about is building things
and along the way i looked for
opportunities to build things and make
things different at the beginning i was
fascinated by biology then by the it
industry
and helping customers doing things
and these days i had the opportunity to
combine both and to
combine agriculture and biology with
technology and they really find it
fascinating their combination
and most likely probably i just love
moving between things and exploring
different angles and try different
things
and if you have to look at it you saw
your specializations
um throughout your career you know what
are you really specializing in
and you know historically where is your
sort of your domain expertise
i think that it's it's funny questions
because for years i was saying that i
don't have a profession
i learned a human science and
then i went into the iit industry
without much
knowledge of computer and gathering
along the way
i think at the end of the day what i
know to do how to do is to manage things
and to execute
and when i have a challenge i'm very
good at breaking it into small
components defining priorities and
making the entire group organization
myself
execute them
and
it's no matter whether it's pouring
custom which is very very relevant these
days
or a
having a building a saffron a farm
it's basically breaking it to small
components understand priorities
understand what is what's the mvp what
are the assets what are the
critical path and how to reach into the
point in the shortest possible way
this is what i love doing and this is i
think what i'm doing best
but still you know we're looking at so
you're talking about problem solving
you're talking about you know
entrepreneurship and zero to one and and
you know the the really you know the
core sense of it yet you're making some
some pretty incredible transitions here
you know for and am docs and cevidia and
you were then an entrepreneur as a
co-founder and then a director within
velocity a director within salesforce
and all of a sudden a shift to saffron
tech so you know what what is it about
the this zero to one or this
entrepreneurial mindset of getting stuff
done that really gets you excited
um
i i think that when i started the
saffron tech when i joined saffrontech
it was running already for you and a
half
and when i spoke with the founder which
said that um he would love me to to lead
the company i told him why why do you
need me what i'm bringing with me
and
it was amazing to realize
that
in each and every steps of the journey i
gather skills and informations
which and capabilities that i can use
and i find very very relevant i think
that for the first time in 15 years i'm
finding all the biology knowledge and
knowing how to plan a laboratory test
coming useful i didn't use this for 15
years
knowing how to manage a project or how
to build technology or how to
define
uh what is the mvp and what are the
assets i'm using it again understanding
all the business aspects
and building the company's strategy
again things that i gather along the way
and small components which allow me to
bring all relevant capabilities and
execute them in saffrontech
and
the way this is the first time i really
act as the ceo of the company
and
the diversity of the position is amazing
need to cover
so many aspects
and understand that even if you believe
that you can do i'm coming from the
technology i just love to dive into the
it area and to dive into the machine
learning and focus there but this is not
what i need to do this part i need to
release to the people who are experts
there and i need to to to be the
facilitator and the enabler of others to
do their job
and i think this is the most fascinating
part of being a ceo
the the ability to enable others to be
amazing in their jobs
incredible i love it the ability to make
others be amazing at their jobs the role
of the ceo you know this zero to one
getting stuff done you know obviously
that that's a huge huge theme here and
still we're talking about a pretty
incredible transition and from
salesforce specifically to saffron tech
what is
saffron and i i believe that i tasted it
at some point maybe uh but but then the
word tech associated with it even more
throws me off tell me a little bit about
that
so saffron tech mission
is to take saffron which is traditional
a corp
growing in the fields today basically
it's about flower blossoming once a year
and the challenge is to trick the nature
and to be able to squeeze
this
year-round cycle and to make it much
much shorter and to take the traditional
farming and move it into an indoor
closely monitored a high-tech
environment
and
the combination from one angle we need
to use a lot of agriculture
and our agronomy needs to understand
the depth of
the nature of this flower and to
understand exactly how can we maximize
it and how can we reach
to the right and the best quality of it
and from the other angle we need to
build all the a technology around it
and when saying technology from one
angle is how to grow it in the most
efficient way and how to have most
optimal growth protocol using a vertical
farming and maximizing and optimizing
the process using machine learning and
ni and
all the nice fancy words around it
and from the other hand to use robotics
in order to enable the automated the
harvesting
of the saffron ensuring the quality of
the saffron and very efficient business
model around it
and to be able to have you know in
nature
at the end of the day there are so many
different variables impacting the
quality of the pork there is the weather
and the water and the duration of the
day and so many different factors
our ability to control them
basically from one angle allowing us
to have a very optimal corp
and to have a very close qa and qe
processes ensuring
best market fit of the saffron to the
market
and when playing saffron all of us
familiar with saffron is a spice but
saffron is much more than that saffron
is an important compound in the health
industry we know in their very
interesting researchers showing that
saffron has great capability to improve
the situation of people with depression
or people with adhd
what i'm fascinated about these days is
how to develop the market
how to reach into the companies that
today if you look at the health industry
and the food supplements you will see
that only very small in the medium if
players
trying to use saffron because today
there is almost no supply chain
everything or the majority of the
saffron arriving from iran with no
guarantee on quantity or quality
and our ability to disrupt this market
is amazing
so the combination of agriculture and
technology
and uh business development and market
developing development is really
fascinating
now if we're looking at saffron
specifically you know what what is
really saffron i'm not really sure too
sure that i know myself
well how what is saffron and and how did
you specifically get into into the world
of saffron
so saffron is go fit it's basically a
and what we are using today as a spice
is the flower stigmas if you look at the
flower there are three red stigmas
within the flower
these are the
uh
the the um parts of the flowers which
are using
for the spice
as i said saffron used is a spice but
it's still in the food industry you see
it a lot in the
uh prestige
cuisine
but you also see it in the health
industry in a very
varied
a
list of products and food supplements
and cosmetics containing saffron
and
the way
i joined the company around the three
months ago the company is already
running for a year and a half so i
cannot say that i came up with this
brilliant idea of favoring saffron
uh
basically the
founder of the company when
he tried to look for
he he he loved
a
consuming saffron as a spice
and when he realized the very high price
he is paying today
and the high demand for saffron he
decided or he felt that there is a real
chance to
distract the market
and to take
this gear fit and move it indoor
when looking today at vertical farming
the majority of the companies growing a
vertical farming
focusing on different kind of grand
green leaves
you see lettuce you see basil you see
other kind of green leaves you don't see
the more complex corpse
and it's not a surprise that they're not
there in order really to take the bulbs
the forms and to move them into vertical
farming you need to have very intimate
knowledge
and very clear
understanding
how the bad is pre-programmed by god or
by nature or depends how you look at the
world but it's
small machine
developed by nature
knows when fall arrives
knows when to flower knows how to
grow and
have very complex life cycle
if we want to interfere with this life
cycle and to challenge it
because if we are just using to grow
saffron as is we won't be able to have
an efficient business model
you need more than 100 flowers of
saffron in order to have one gram of
saffron spice
it just doesn't make sense from vertical
farming point of view
yes the ability to have a real efficient
business model
an efficient grow
of gofet
is to trick nature and make him
understand
that fall is coming more often than once
again
and this attempt of playing in nature or
playing god and the full
the girlfriend is amazing when we'll
know how to do it we'll be able to go to
many many other
ego fits used today and no one even
started
to grow them in vertical farming like
onion or like garlic
and you know when speaking about green
agriculture and being environment
friendly
i don't think that
we will be able to have a salad
without onion or without a garlic
so these questions needs to be solved
and saffron allows us easily solve them
because the very high market value of it
so we can allow ourselves the benefit of
growing and playing and optimizing the
process then we'll be able to
implement the knowledge on other
graphics as well
and the market if we're looking at the
size of the market and the potential
here
so when looking at the markets of
saffron today the saffron is more or
less one billion dollar market
but there are
endless amount the the amount of fake
saffron in the market is very high
and the data we have about saffron
because the majority of the corp coming
from iran
again is not very clear and we believe
that there are some mistakes around it
we believe that
when we will provide a stable supply
chain of saffron
we will see significant increase in the
market size because we
have much bigger players
using saffron in their products whether
it's saffron tea or saffron cookies or
saffron cream
so i expect that when we will talk in
three years from today
the discussion about the market will be
significantly different than just
focusing on the food industry which is
the current focus of suffering markets
now is this always something that you
knew that you wanted to get into food
tech agritech is this has this always
been a part of tal
tal's journey here
not at all
i hope it's the right answer but it's
the truth i never thought that i will
come back to biology
i was in a very clear
you know looking at the last 10 years i
mean the i.t and cloud areas talking
about digital transformation and
entirely different industries i always
like biology i was fascinated by
agriculture but i really didn't see a
way to combine them into my professional
world and when i met the founder of the
company and had the chance of joining
i
it felt like all pieces are combining
and building the right story
and
the chance of combining the two is is
really fascinating i think it's
it's it's i i'm very i found myself
going to work very happy these days i'm
finding myself fascinated by the
discussions i have not only with the
technical people when i feel i have
their own answers and they saw similar
things and speaking with double nominees
i feel entire paradigm that i was not
aware of it's really
really inspiring i love it challenging
each and every day
and i just love the you know these
feelings but but i have to ask you know
if from a leadership perspective you
know running a company like this
versus you know you're in foodtech
versus being you know the other
companies that you've experienced that
are you know that are fast-growing tech
companies what is the vibe like what is
the project management or the day-to-day
like different between you know your
experience now with saffron tech versus
in your previous organizations
so
for years now i was saying that a good
manager is a good manager and you need
to understand enough but you don't need
to be the expert in order to manage
um
coming to saffrontech i realized that
the speed
of a development is entirely different
after coming for years from the software
industry
saying you cannot
have a baby in
one month by nine women
um
i realized that in agrotech it's much
much more complex
so when looking at the aggro tech
industry versus traditional software
industry where i came from
the
challenges around agrotech are the
duration of tests especially when
talking about their fate
when talking about their fights the
timeline
or the life cycle
is around the year
when we are trying to squeeze them then
we are going to have a four months or
five months a round of a
test
it's very very long cycles when you have
such long cycles you need to manage and
plan them very carefully each mistakes
going to cost you in a delay of
three or four or five months and in life
cycle of a startup company it's endless
it's much much more than in software
industry and it's much more than you can
afford yourself
so the need
to have very close planning and very
close management is much more
significant in other software companies
when they work before and also there it
was complex so it's take everything i
know about management and about planning
and push them to the extreme
i love it and then todd i really want to
thank you for for this time and energy
and it's a little surprising career
change but i love you know the i love
the insights and i love your personal
your personal endeavor in the way that
you're so intentionally understanding
where your passions lie and there's zero
to one then getting stuff done
understanding the cultural differences
understanding the potential and and
being open to these new opportunities is
something that i can just wish for
myself and so i really want to thank you
for the time and the energy best of luck
with saffron tech i can't wait to see
where you're where you're going to take
innovation with combination of food and
vertical farming and machinery and so
that we can um you know all enjoy it
much more so thank you very very much
thank you very much for having me here
today
thank you
[Music]